[Waves crashing]
[Gulls cawing]
♪♪♪
- Now, I'm at the point where
the work is gonna show.
I feel like I put a lotta hours in.
I sacrificed a lotta stuff, so.
[Crowd cheering]
If you don't believe in
yourself, then who really will?
- Gimme three!
- [Clapping]
- Gimme two! Gimme one!
♪♪♪
One, two, three!
- [In unison:] Boom!
[Whistle blowing]
- OK. What's up?
I'm Simeon Wilcher, class of 2023.
I'm a University of North Carolina commit.
- [Offscreen:] All right, perfect.
Thank you.
- Growin' up, I wasn't
really, I wasn't really a basketball player.
I started really takin'
basketball serious
at around, like, seven, eight years old.
Like, just bein' around,
watchin' everybody play
and goin' to high school games.
Me and my pops would travel.
Me and my pops, my brother, my mom.
So that just helped, like,
grow my love for it.
And then over the years, watchin' players,
my love is growin' by the day.
[Buzzer sounding]
♪♪♪
Sometimes I catch myself watchin'
highlight reels of myself.
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:] Simeon Wilcher!
- Like, that's what I used to do.
Man, I used to go on YouTube
and just watch players hoop.
And so now it's just like,
it's kinda crazy to me
that I know somewhere out there
that somebody's actually
searchin' my name up
on Google and watchin' me play.
As a hooper, you really
motivate people to keep goin'.
So knowin' that I could actually help
somebody, somebody out there get through whatever
they're goin' through means a lot.
[Buzzer sounding]
- [Announcer:] Simeon Wilcher,
for three!
[Players talking]
- [Simeon:] Puttin' on the
jersey for Roselle means a lot.
Knowin' that the recent
history in the last 10 years,
that Roselle's won three ToCs,
like, that means a lot.
Not everybody is blessed
with the opportunity.
[Players clapping]
- Gimme one!
- [Clapping]
- Gimme two!
- Gimme three!
- [Clapping]
- One, one, one! When I
say three, you say four!
One, two, three!
- [In unison:] Boom!
♪♪♪
- Freshman year, I was the
little brother to everybody.
Yeah, really all of my older brothers
on the team with me.
I always played with a chip on my shoulder
because some people, like, just tossed me
to the side a little bit, and
I don't really like that.
And also I feed off, like, my older brother.
But he didn't really get to shine
that I feel like he deserved.
So that just adds to
the chip on my shoulder.
I feel like I'm doin' it for him too.
♪♪♪
[Players clapping]
- And we know we can beat people
when we play our best, OK?
Today was a good game
against a good national team
with a couple of really good players.
Didn't have our A-game,
still found a way to win
by doin' the things that we needed to do.
All right? Congratulations.
Good win. Bring it in.
[Players clapping]
- What I want for my future
involving basketball,
I want it to take me to the NBA.
Not only just to be a
player and just get drafted.
I wanna be a superstar
and be a role model for the younger kids.
I love basketball.
I love basketball, and my
love is just gonna grow
as the years go on.